nous sommes avec laurent rochus
directeur artistique de la factory
avignon au réseau de lieux dédiés à la
pratique et la représentation des arts
vivants avignon bonsoir laurent rochus à
vos côtés pour en débattre donc noël à
jour y président de l'union des métiers
et des industries de l'hôtellerie miss
côte d'azur bonsoir à vous également
merci d'être en direct sur rtl france on
en parlait avec m jardin faire certains
restaurateurs qui ont donc décidé
d'ouvrir
malgré les interdictions malgré même les
menaces de bruno le maire ce matin je
vous propose d'écouter justement le
ministre de l'économie avant dans park
les restaurateurs qui ouvre ne
bénéficieront plus du fonds de
solidarité pendant un mois
et s'il ya récidive ils le perdront tout
court alors question les menaces de
bruno le maire ont-elles casser le
mouvement vous trouvez ça normal ou
choquant à l'instar de l'avocat avec
lequel on vient de s'entretenir noël à
jour i mais je pense que monsieur le
maire a voulu frapper fort avec cette
annonce ce matin c'est ça qui a fait
freiné un peu si vous voulez les
restaurateurs qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient ouvrir malgré l'interdiction
malgré la fermeture administrative
nous avons appelé depuis plusieurs jours
au calme parce que nous avons eues à
nice un cas d'un restaurateur qui a
voulu braver et en freiner la loi et qui
a ouvert qui a eu des problèmes avec la
justice
je comprends le désarroi
je comprends la tristesse de toulouse
les restaurateurs de nos collègues
restaurateurs
parce que moi aussi les deux heures à
nice j'ai une vingtaine d'employés je
comprends qu est-ce que c'est des
athlètes des établissements fermés mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'on va aller contre
la loi et contrôler les décisions
administratives
alors on parle des restaurateurs
que vous représentez ce soir mais ça
grogne aussi du côté des théâtres nom de
la culture qui souffrent également
laurent rocheux vous même vous avez
lancé samedi l'opération théâtre ouvert
pendant une heure une opération donc
symbolique 1 rapidement interrompues
d'ailleurs par la police ouvrir alors
que vous aviez l'interdiction de fermer
ces de la désobéissance civile pour vous
de l'insurrection ou simplement des
actions coup de poing pour se faire
entendre
non c'était d'abord une interpellation
du ministère c'est qu'on a voulu faire
un raisonnement par l'absurde le fait
que des théâtres où c'est ça qui
déclenche tout l'écosystème de l'art
vivant en france
si les théâtres ne voit pas notamment
l'été acquittent les théâtres qui
achètent des spectacles ce sont les
théâtres municipaux l'étape qui ont des
régie ou délégation de service public
aujourd'hui le tout l'art vivant est en
panne à cause de cette ouverture de
théâtre et comme aujourd'hui nous sommes
devant un ministère qui a décidé
d'indemniser l'art vivant avec une un
dispositif qui ne marche pas on est en
train nous sur le terrain d'assister à
une véritable hémorragie et a surtout à
une extinction des espèces l'art vivant
en est un est un est un est un domaine
avec des acteurs très plurielle
il ya en gros des institutions qui sont
soutenus par le ministère cela ils sont
ils ont ils ont des fondations en béton
il ya des entrepreneurs de spectacles
qui sont des grosses boîtes de
production qui financent je dirais une
industrie du divertissement et du et du
loisir culturel ça c'est pas péjoratif
et c'est pas du tout honteux
et puis il ya aussi énormément et
surtout des artisans qui sont plus ou
moins en avant garde sur la recherche en
création et plus ou moins aidé par les
territoires c'est dans ce vivier là qui
représente plus de la moitié des
compagnies d'arts vivants qu'en ce
moment on va assister je crains d'ici
cet été à une grande déperdition une
extinction des espèces
donc c'est pour appelé le ministère à
faire très attention à cette extinction
d'espèces parce qu'on subodore que ça
pourrait arranger peut-être le ministère
ou en tout cas certaines personnes qu'
il ya un peu moins de productions
théâtrales en france un peu moins de
compagnies qui est une sélection
naturelle qu'on reste un peu dans
l'antre soit des grandes scènes
conventionnées
c'est pour attirer l'attention du
ministère qu'on a fait cette opération
mais si vous voulez
on a piégé un peu si vous voulez
l'institution on a eu des magnifiques
photos de d'agents de police barrant une
porte de théâtre je crois que pour un
régime démocratique comme le nôtre de se
rendre coupable de cette triste pièce
d'avoir des agents de police qui barrent
les bords de théâtre il nous en ferons
une image magnifique et puis surtout ça
nous a pas mis nous de prendre le micro
pour interpeller donc roselyne bachelot
sur ce sujet et aussi et surtout attiré
son attention sur l'année blanche
il faut très vite que l'année blanche
souhaite annoncer le renouvellement de
l'année blanche parce que les
intermittents qui sont complètement
dépendants de ce statut pour pouvoir
imaginer qu'à partir du 1er septembre
prochain ils auront un avenir
professionnel
on peut pas les faire attendre comme
roselyne bachelot à la fin il ya dix
jours disent on va voir on va réfléchir
non on va se retrouver avec huit mois
quasiment 2 saisons les teintes et de la
moindre des choses c'est de leur dire
tout de suite rassurez vous
quand on quand on protège les plus
faibles quoi qu'il en coûte comme dirait
le président c'est au plus faible qu'on
doit d'abord à porter cette parole d'h
on va vous aider évidemment on vous
laissera pas avec cette incertitude trop
longtemps au dessus de la tête oui on
est très imaginatif donc nous si vous
voulez la prochaine fois on a le
ministère de la parole c'est notre force
le mil le gouvernement à les chiffrer et
à les gendarmes mais nous on a
l'imagination et la force de
l'imagination c'est d'être un fini donc
on a eu une idée cette fois c'était de
faire croire qu'on allait ouvrir tous
les clubs de france pour mettre le
système en panique
la prochaine fois on aura d'autres idées
voilà alors la désobéissance civile en
tout cas c'est un terme employé par de
nombreux politiques en ce moment vous
bénéficiez de soutien dans vos démarches
messieurs comme par exemple florian
philippot le président des patriotes qui
est vent debout contre la fermeture
notamment des restaurants écouter
l'ennemi public numéro 1 est désormais
le restaurateur dix clandestins
c'est à dire qu'ils bossent des ordres
terrible ont été donnés contre eux des
français honnêtes travailleurs qui n'en
peuvent plus d'être maltraitée par un
pouvoir irresponsable on vit des heures
très sombres
l'ennemi public c'est le restaurateur
1,7 sentiment que vous avez vous aussi
noël à jour hissé
le ras-le-bol qui monte alors qu'on le
rappelle quand même hein y'a il ya des
aides tout même qu'ils sont accordé des
aides plutôt généreuse en france mais
malgré tout vous avez ce sentiment
d'injustice aujourd'hui mais le
sentiment d'injustice nous l'avons
depuis le début parce que on n'a pas
encore prouvé que les restaurateurs ou
si vous voulez le virus se propage plus
chez les restaurateurs ou dans nos
établissements qu'ailleurs on se base
toujours sur une étude américaine qui
date de plusieurs mois en arrière
la france n'a pas été capable d'apporter
une nouvelle étude fiable devant le
conseil d'état
et malgré ça le conseil d'état a rejeté
notre demande il ya deux mois quand on a
demandé devant l'opposer d'état au nom
de notre syndicat la réouverture de
l'établissement
concernant le deuxième volet concernant
le deuxième volet vous dit les aides
sont généreuses je veux des pays comme
les etats unis ou voilà où il n'y a
quasiment pas des dents c'est vrai tout
à fait je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous mais n'oubliez pas que ces aides
sont conditionnées alors et aujourd'hui
il ya plus que 35 pour son voire 40% des
restaurateurs n'arrive pas à toucher ses
aides et jette ça je parle des
restaurateurs sans parler d'autres
métiers sont parlé des commerçants qui
sont fermés qu'on a obligé à fermer
comment vous expliquez que un
restaurateur qui a ouvert en 2020 n'a
pas le droit aux aides pourquoi c'est
son argent il a un déficit et s'est
endetté il a mis tout pour tout son
argent toute son énergie pour ouvrir une
affaire et aujourd'hui on lui dit tu
fermes dans l'établissement fin octobre
on a fermé l'établissement
et quand il demande l'aide ou le fonds
de solidarité on le dit non t'as pas le
droit parce que tu as ouvert contre
septembre ou en octobre de l'année
dernière alors que toute l'année
dernière les présidents et le président
découvre le gouvernement des
responsables politiques nous pousser à
investir
le tout c'est tout le monde
seulement les restaurateurs ou c'est
tout le monde à investir en france et
aujourd'hui on leur dit non vous êtes
devant un mur vous n'avez pas le droit
et tous les jours on est confronté à ça
tous les jours on est obligé de passer
par des commissions et des commissions
pour obtenir des aides la saison là et
sachez une chose que on aura beaucoup de
malheurs d'ici quelques temps si ça
continue comme ça je n'appelle pas à la
désobéissance civile
pas du tout j'appelle tous les
restaurateurs et tous les commerçants au
calme parce qu'avec le calme on arrivera
peut-être avec le gouvernement à trouver
une solution mais il faut que le
gouvernement nous aide rapidement à
trouver cette solution là que ce soit
pour vous que ce soit pour le théâtre
que ce soit pour l'espé pour les salles
de jeux de sport pour tous les
établissements qui sont frappés
aujourd'hui de fermeture administrative
il faut absolument et en urgence que le
gouvernement monsieur le maire -ministre
de l'économie monsieur le président qui
nous ont dit ils laisseront jamais
personne à la rue de nous aider pour
trouver des solutions rapides parce que
c'est pas vrai tout ce qu'ils ont dit
que aujourd'hui ils nous ont dit que
monsieur le maire a annoncé ce matin que
des centres commerciaux qui sont fermés
depuis hier ils vont avoir
ils vont bénéficier des aides pour les
loyers alors que nous les restaurateurs
nous n'avons pas eu ça les salles de jeu
les restaurateurs là qui sont en colère
on l'aura compris je me repose comme
d'écouter aussi l'avis médical un an
l'un des avis parce qu'il faut bien le
dire les médecins ne sont pas tous
d'accord entre eux mais enfin la
montreuil professeur gilbert dorée chef
du service de néphrologie à la pitié
salpêtrière lui et pour un confinement
total les français sont épuisés par un
an de pandémie et de destruction de
l'économie et du tissu social la seule
solution c'est un confinement total
associé à une vaccination massive
n'ayant pas les doses et pour éviter la
mutinerie des révoltés du confinement
nous procrastine ont alors laurent rosso
est ce que ce n'est pas ça qu'il
faudrait faire un confinement total
quitte à rouvrir après d'ailleurs
voir l'italie ouvre ses restaurants
notamment aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
écoutez dans l'histoire il ya eu de
complot des blouses blanches je voudrais
pas qu'on ait la république des blouses
blanches
c'est très bien que le gouvernement par
principe de précaution juridique se
cache en permanence derrière des avis
d'experts
mais gouverner c'est aussi prendre des
responsabilités en dehors de ça nous on
est pas du tout là pour expliquer qu'on
ait des infectiologues
encore une fois je répète que notre
action elle n'était pas de dire faut
qu'on rouvre vite s'était attiré
l'attention du gouvernement sur le fait
que nos dispositifs qui est en place
pour indemniser les compagnies je dis
bien des compagnies n'est pas du tout
opérationnel il rend service aux plus
gros et ils laissent les les petits les
indépendants dans une bonne situation
d'hémorragie qui fait qu'ils ne verront
pas l'été et les festivals c'est ça
notre intention donc on va pas débattre
nous les poètes les les histrions avec
avec des infectiologues où on a perdu
par contre en tant qu'intellectuel et en
tant que citoyen on peut se poser la
question de ce que signifie qu'à un goût
un gouvernement qui de son olympe
jupitérien interpose entre le peuple et
lui en permanence des experts et court
circuite l'assemblée pour qu'il ait pas
de débat ça c'est autre chose ça je sors
du gier et de mon rôle de directeur de
théâtre peut-être là une fois qu'on a
dit ça
nous on se range derrière la ville
infectiologues on n'a pas du tout envie
de briser des périodes de confinement si
on de nous dire là qu'il faudra confiné
drastiquement si suisse mène mais
qu'après la vaccination suivant son
cours
on va pouvoir enfin un petit à petit
aller vers un printemps français
d'ailleurs il faudra tête se méfier de
ce printemps français on ne sait pas et
un été où les festivals vont enfin
refleurir et que nous cigalon puisse
penser qu'à cigale et voilà notre métier
c'est de faire les cigales et
aujourd'hui on est obligé de prendre les
armes de devenir des fourmis soldats ça
ne va pas donc on voudrait très bien
très vite retourner à nos métiers de
cigales et en attendant et bien confie
non s'il faut mais par contre pendant ce
confinement
il faut qu'au ministère on nous entende
il faut vite sécurisé les intermittents
parce que c'est les plus fragiles de
tous les salariés en france parce que
l'enfant leur statut et est très ténue
et qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de le
laisser dans une expectative où ils se
demandent pour la plupart d'entre eux si
au 1er septembre ils seront pas au rsa
on peut pas laisser les gens sans dormir
avec cette boule au ventre wada tous les
soirs c'est inadmissible c'est de la
plus haute et mentale
première chose et puis gîte on remet un
petit peu la technicité de
l'indemnisation sur la table on se
réunit en deux trois semaines et je
pense qu'on pourra trouver une façon
d'indemniser les compagnies qui sera
plus légitime et beaucoup qui
corresponde à beaucoup mieux à la
réalité de leurs pertes
voilà c'est tout après nous on laisse ce
qu'on finisse ils veulent on aura on est
toujours libre dans nos têtes voilà
merci en tout cas tous les deux laurent
rochus noël à jour et d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france